durch meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft tier und zwar der
letzten warum allgemein in den letzten
tagen so wenig videos kam und warum ich
mich so komisch anhören warum ich
gestern nicht dabei war sage ich euch
alles nach dem intro also wir schon seit
ich sie total fertig aus also das liegt
jetzt vielleicht auch daran dass ihr die
lichtverhältnisse ein bisschen karte
sind aber ich bin halt einfach extrem
krank ich weiß nicht ob man das auch an
meiner stimme hört dich denkmal schon
und wenn man es nicht hört dass wir das
halt trotzdem vielleicht irgendwie
glauben könnte das wäre sind und zwar
tut mir ganz erhalt wie wenn ich morgens
aufwache brennt mein ganzer als ich bin
aber eine totale erkältung und das seit
samstagnachmittag und deswegen kam am
sonntag ein video und montag habe jetzt
auch kein video heute komplett wieder
zwei weil ich mich dass durch quelle und
wir hatten halt gesagt dass wir am
sonntagabend um 8 uhr treffen und das
alles aufnehmen also diese cent in
dieser entziehen da mehr oder weniger wo
wir dann alle zusammen noch mal ganz
viele prostituierte so eine gemeinsame
aktion zum ende und dann noch den
downloadlink bereitstellen
da war ich aber schon am kennen weil und
also nicht um 8 uhr schon am panel aber
ich wollte halt schon pennen gehn und
lag dann im bett und hatte halt mega
schmerzen überall also ich war ko ich
hatte ich war caro ich hatte
halsschmerzen augen schmerzt also meine
augen immer zu gefallen das war richtig
richtig krass einfach ich habe noch nie
so eine krasse erkältung das ist zurzeit
als aufstand der besserung auf dem weg
der besserung
hoffe ich zumindest also ich bin jetzt
nicht zum arzt gegangen oder so ich kann
auch nicht mehr auf den server drauf
gehen also der ist nicht mehr verfügbar
allerdings werde ich jetzt einfach so
eine test welt von mir eingehen und dann
noch mal ein bisschen herum fliegen
einfach so also das war seine welt weil
ich immer so ein paar sachen getestet
habe und da wie zum beispiel dass ccp
ist gerade gemacht habe ich zum beispiel
die häuser aufgebaut wie ich die bauen
wollte da hab ich sogar bei den häusern
extrem crafting trading gestellt dass
alles versucht im survival mode
aufzubauen habe ich genau weiß wie viel
blöcke ich von allen möglichen kag
brauche um das alles passend
herzustellen und ja so würden reiche
heute aussehen ich wollte endlich mit
der ccp antreten
allerdings hat das hier alles nicht mehr
so ganz geklappt weil dort projekte
jetzt zu ende ist falls es noch nicht
mitbekommen habe das projekt ist beendet
weil wir etwas neues besseres vorhaben
und viele leute auch schon dass der
koloss mit sondern früher hier und viele
leute auch schon sehr sehr viel erreicht
habe ihr euch jetzt einfach hier durch
andere seite ja gar nichts das auch noch
jetzt buch
kollegen wo bin ich zusätzlich bisschen
was das denn monolith euro
das hier irgendwie tracy hier aus kann
ich jetzt kollegen wie komme ich weiß
nicht wo ich hier bin ich mache jetzt
erstmal den ton aus und habe jetzt erst
mal so ein bisschen und zwar was soll
ich hier will wie komme ich wieder aus
ich bin die ganze zeit in dieser scheiße
drin
es kommt zu mir her das ist bestimmt so
eine dimension oder sogar ja nie drin
sein würde ich auch was zu sagen ich war
ja hallo du hast wieder die tür
jetzt können wir die tore machen und
zwar war es bei mir immer ich bin also
ein spätstarter einen solchen sachen
also dann brauche ich dann brauch ich
mal eure tipps und so et cetera pp
aber da möchte ich mich an euch bedanken
an dieser stelle dass ihr mir da so
krass goodbye geholfen habt in hexe 3 zu
finden mit tipps tricks taktiken im
kampf et cetera was sich auf die sachen
drauf zaubern soll
und ja ich denke es war insgesamt also
ein sehr schönes projekt ich könnte es
genauso sein was ihr am ende von mega
projekt auch gesagt habe also ihr habt
auf jeden fall einen downloadlink in der
beschreibung dann nicht mal ganz oben
drin ist immer nur so eine scheiße ist
hier drin also am anfang hat für mich
gut also was ich halt eigentlich noch
machen wollte in hero ist halt die
häuser zu ende bauen dann war endlich
die kisten richtig sortieren und mehr
halt eine folge wollte ich komplett
machen wo ich einfach nur von dem opfer
nahe stehe bis ich in die 100 level up
und meine ganze sache noch heftigste zu
verzaubert also den legia bogen scale
out finden sind ein paar sachen die ich
machen wollte aber konnte ich jetzt halt
nicht mehr weil es bringt jetzt zu ende
ist was aber auch gut so ist
weil jetzt halt was neues kommt und das
neue das wollen wir halt noch nicht so
genau sagen das wird halt bald wittert
losgehen auch gemacht
aluminium er bald wieder losgehen ihr
werdet schon noch früh genug mitbekommen
wandert sein wird
wir werden schon noch früh genug
mitbekommen wann das sein wird ich hoffe
dass ich bis dahin wieder fit bin weil
ich halt zurzeit ich hoffe man hört
recht einfach total amanos bin ich bin
total fertig ist das und eventuell wird
die tag auch noch mal was anderes kommen
so als übergang mehr oder weniger noch
mal bis zu diesem neuen projekt wo auch
viele aus jeder dabei sein werden bzw
alle also es darf jeder mitmachen ob
jeder will weiß ich jetzt nicht
ich denke aber schon und ja das war es
eigentlich so meine letzten worte ist
auf jeden fall cool so ein paar meine
schönste aktion zum beispiel bei mir die
ich am witzigsten fand war als ich mit
revier unterwegs war dann auf einmal
drei endermann an karmann nicht ein herz
hatte das kann ich mega witzig oder mit
den alten eine folge die mega witzig war
wo wir erst in seiner stadt war damit
schon fast getötet und als ersteller
schöne landschaft hier
das muss ich ja also es gab sehr viele
coole momente familien meine lieblings
moment ihr könnt ihr mal schreiben dass
eure lieblings moment in hero waren das
wird mich auf jeden fall interessieren
und dann will ich sagen freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat und wenn ihr mir
wirklich gute besserung wünscht dann
schreibt nicht eine kommentare gute
besserung sondern lasse auf eine
bewertung da ihr könnt auch schreiben an
die super nett seid lexika alles
verbindlich
ich weiß jetzt eine sehr schöne ecke
hier hier hätte ich mir so perfektion
auf so die stars blabla naja freundlich
wird sagen ich hoffe euch hat die folge
trotzdem gefallen auch einsetzen tag
später kam
und wenn ich fertig bin aber ich hoffe
ich akzeptiert dass ich einfach richtig
tragen bin
und ja sonst würde ich sagen kollegen
kollegen sonnenschein wir sehen uns
morgen oder heute abend bei den fans
wieder und dann nochmal danke für die
ganze gemeinsame zeit in heroes war sehr
schön
ich liebe euch alle